الله جن اللهم جن اللهم جن اللهم جن اللهم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله. اما بعد يقول
الحافظ الفقيه الامام النووي رحمه الله
تعالى
في رياضه
في باب التوبه في الحديث الثاني
وعن ابي نجيد
عمران بن الحسين الخزاعي رضي الله عنهما.
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
رياض الصالحين 2
نجيد عمران بن الحسين رضي الله عنه
ابو نجيد
name عمران
name
الحص
النووي رضي الله عنهما
الله
عمران بن الحسين رضي الله عنه
اسلامق
‏differans
andنable
صلى الله عليه
‏amions
meaning meaning that he had many
illnesses that he fought throughout the
entir of life
he mainly suffered from ae
which was in the books حديث الاستسقاء
مرض الاستسقاء
waser
to english
more modern asema
so
fluid
‏to that
bec
and become
this com of a deficiency inver function
or in kidney function
impossible for us to know which of those
was exactly the diagnosis but ‏suffنه
also suff from
البواسير البواسير which are
hemid commonly known as hemoroids where
the fine veins in the rectum become
very inflamed
‏And you know in our days today these
things have some kind of
recourse for person who
is suffering from these types of things
in the propet's
days
wouldaim a person's life very easily
couldaim a person's life and
because of hisid
[Silence]
ى عليه وسلم
رضي الله
الانصار رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلي قائما فان لم تستطع فقاعدا فان لم
تستطع فعلى جنب هذه من روايه عمران بن
الحسين
رضي الله عنه ونعلم سبب هذه الروايه اذ
صاحب البواسير لا يستطيع اي قد لا يستطيع
القيام قد لا يستطيع الجلوس فقال له النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم صلي قائما فان لم
تستطع فقاعدا فان لم تستطع فعلى جنب رضي
الله عنهم
صحيح البخاري
[Silence]
andران
الحسين
صلى الله عليه وسلمح
البخاري
‏unableaying
and was
عمران الحسين
‏different
primitive surgeries at the time that
him and one of those surgeries that they
would do at the time is they would
lerally cut the bell and try to drain
the fluids and take out any excess fat
any excess things in the bell that a
person could do
‏someess
and
because of this constant opening of the
bell to drain
his bell he was in a very state to
and so man came to him while was
said to
يا ابا حسين او يا ابا نجيد عفوا يا ابا
نجيد انه ليمنعني من زيارتك
ما ارى من حالك فقال له
اذا يا اخي فلا تاتني فاني ارضى
بما رضي الله من امري رضي الله عنه
‏man said to him I don'tit you as much
as I should because of the state that in
difficult for me to see you
and so said to him don't come because I
choose for myself whatah chen for me
this is there nothing here is badally
for theران
is one of
عليهم السلام كانت الملائكه
تسلم عليه
في عصر وفي حياه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وبعد حياته صلى الله عليه وسلم
فكانت الملائكه
تسلم عليه كيف ذلك النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول والذي نفسي بيده
لو
تكونون
في بيوتكم
على ما تكونون عليه في الذكر لصافحتكم
الملائكه في الطرقات كان عمران منهم رضي
الله عنه قال فاكتويت يعني من جراء المرض
اكتوى
فامتنعت الملائكه
لان الكي
الكي
ا منزه عنه
فتركت الكي فعادوا
رضي الله عنهم
angلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عمران بن الحسين رضي الله عنه
هجره
الكوفه العراق عمران بن الحسين رضي الله
عنه
اسلام نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه
وجوده ان يجمعنا جميعا
في جناته النعيم مع النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وصحابته
الاكرمين والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد